.
>>> LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US.
THIS IS "RANGE BATTLES"
PRESENTED BY CAPITAL ONE.
WE'RE HERE IN BEAUTIFUL BIG SKY,
MONTANA.
IT'S GOING TO BE A LOT OF FUN.
I KNOW A LOT OF YOU AT HOME ARE
PROBABLY VERY CONFUSED ABOUT
EXACTLY WHAT'S GOING ON RIGHT
NOW.
THIS IS "RANGE BATTLES."
THERE ARE SUPERSTARS ON THE
COURSE WARMING UP FOR THE MATCH.
TOM BRADY, AARON RODGERS, BRYSON
DECHAMBEAU AND PHIL MICHELSON.
OUR GOAL IS TO GET ALL OF THEM
TO DRILL WEST.
WE'RE GOING TO GIVE A TON OF
MONEY TO YOU GUYS IF YOU
CORRECTLY GUESS WHO WINS TODAY.
WE'LL BE DONATING A THOUSAND
MEALS.
FOR NOW WE'RE SEEING CHUCK WARM
UP, CHEYENNE AND FITZ WARM UP.
>> IT DON'T LOOK THAT GOOD.
>> IT'S SO BAD.
>> HOPEFULLY HE'S WORKED ON THAT
STRING, MAN.
>> LEAVE COMMENTS IN THE COMMENT
CONNECTION AND I WILL BE PICKING
THE FUNNIEST ONES AND THE BEST
ONES AND READING THEM OUT LOUD.
>> WE HAVE TWO SUPERSTAR
QUARTERBACKS ON THE COURSE
GETTING READY TO WARM UP.
WHICH QUARTERBACK WOULD YOU
RATHER HAVE ON YOUR TEAM IN
2021?
>> ME PERSONALLY?
IS THIS EVEN A QUESTION?
DO YOU NOT KNOW WHAT HAPPENED
LAST YEAR?
>> I WAS GOING TO SAY BRADY.
IT'S $100 TO THE BEST COMMENT.
DON'T JUST TELL ME BRADY OR
RODGERS.
I WANT TO HEAR EXACTLY.
>> I WANT TO KNOW WHY, WHETHER
IT'S FUNNY, WHETHER IT'S
SERIOUS, WHETHER YOU GOT STATS,
I WANT TO KNOW WHY.
>> I LOVE IT.
>> MVP.
>> SEVEN-TIME SUPER BOWL
CHAMPION.
YOU KNOW, HE HAS MORE RINGS BY
HIMSELF THAN THE ENTIRE NFL,
THAN ANY TEAM IN THE NFL.
>> I KNOW.
I CAN'T BET AGAINST BRADY.
>> YOU JUST DID.
WHAT HAPPENED LAST TIME YOU BET
AGAINST BRADY?
>> IT JUST DIDN'T GO WELL.
BEFORE I GET HEATED TOO HARD
TODAY, I GOT TO GO DOWN TO MY
MAN IN THE CART.
WEST IS DRIVING THE CART TODAY.
HOW YOU FEELING, BRO?
>> YOU GUYS ARE ALREADY HITTING
ME.
>> YOU NERVOUS YET?
>> THEY'RE ON TARGET TODAY.
>> THAT'S GOOD.
>> ARE YOU GOOD?
>> WE HAVE A FEW OPEN SPOTS
HERE, BUT I FEEL GOOD.
I FEEL SAFER WITH YOU GUYS IN MY
EAR, THAT'S FOR SURE.
>> WE HAVE A CHALLENGE FOR
EVERYONE WATCHING.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO START THIS
UNTIL I ANNOUNCE IT.
DON'T DROP YOUR GUESSES YET.
THE CHALLENGE IS, WHO WILL HIT
THE CART FIRST?
>> ALREADY GOT A DINGER.
>> SO DROP YOUR COMMENTS RIGHT
NOW.
LET US KNOW WHO YOU THINK IS
GOING TO HIT THE CART FIRST.
>> CHEYENNE WOODS.
>> I GOT MY MONEY ON CHEYENNE.
>> ARE YOU ALL RIGHT DOWN THERE?
>> OH, WOW.
>> YOU ALL RIGHT?
>> SHOULD WE GO FIRST --
>> TALK SOME SMACK.
>> THE KING OF PHOENIX, CHARLES
BARKLEY.
>> THE KING OF PHOENIX.
YOU'RE NOT IN PHOENIX.
IS CHEYENNE FIRST?
>> MY MONEY IS ON CHEYENNE.
SHE'S SMACKING IT, BRO.
>> CHARLES HAD NINE TEQUILAS ON
THE ROCKS LAST NIGHT.
>> YOU MIGHT HAVE TO MOVE
CLOSER.
LOOK AT THAT SWING.
REPLAY FROM CHEYENNE.
EASY.
>> WEST, YOU CAN'T FLINCH.
>> THAT'S IMPOSSIBLE, BOYS.
>> DO I NEED SCOOT UP?
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> CALM DOWN, LITTLE FELLA.
>> I LOVE IT.
HEY, EVERYONE WATCHING AT HOME,
WEST GOT A MEGAPHONE.
HE CAN COMMUNICATE.
>> I DON'T THINK CHUCK HAS HIT A
SINGLE BALL YET.
>> THESE GUYS ARE ACTUALLY
REALLY GOOD AT THIS.
>> CHEYENNE IS --
>> RELAX, MAN.
I'M IN ARIZONA RIGHT NOW.
RELAX.
WE'RE SUPPORTING THE SUNS.
>> THAT IS MONEY.
CHEYENNE IS MONEY.
EVERYONE IS HITTING ME BUT
CHUCK.
>> I HOPE YOU GUYS DROP IN THE
COMMENTS THAT CHEYENNE WAS GOING
TO WIN.
IF YOU DIDN'T, YOU MIGHT HAVE
JUST PLAYED YOURSELF.
>> THAT'S A $200 BET RIGHT
THERE.
IF YOU CORRECTLY GUESSED WHO'S
GOING TO HIT THE CART FIRST,
WE'RE GIVING AWAY $200 EACH TO
FOUR WINNERS.
>> PULL UP CLOSE TO CHUCK AND
LET HIM KNOW YOU'RE HELPING HIM
OUT.
>> HOW CLOSE IS HE?
>> THERE WE GO, CHARLES.
>> THAT IS A CHIP SHOT.
THAT IS NOT EVEN IN THE SAME
STRATOSPHERE.
>> WHAT IS HE AIMING AT?
>> CHUCK JUST SENT IT HARD
RIGHT.
>> OH MY GOD.
HIS SWING LOOKS BETTER, BUT I
DON'T KNOW IF IT'S GETTING THE
JOB DONE, BRO.
>> CHEYENNE IS LIKE 80% FROM THE
FIELD, THOUGH.
>> CASA AMIAMIGOS.
>> DEAR LORD.
>> THEY ARE SMACKING.
>> WES, I'LL DONATE A THOUSAND
MEALS MYSELF IF YOU DON'T FLINCH
WHEN THE NEXT BALL HITS YOU.
>> READY?
>> STONE COLD.
I'M NOT GOING TO MOVE.
>> LOOKS LIKE WE GOT OUR FIRST
WINNERS, LADIES AND GENTLEMEN.
THESE FOUR GUESSED THAT CHEYENNE
WOODS IS GOING TO BE THE FIRST
TO HIT THE GOLF CART.
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
200 BUCKS JUST FOR GUESSING.
>> JUST FOR BEING HERE WITH US.
>> IF YOU DIDN'T GUESS CHEYENNE
WOODS, IT RUNS IN HER BLOODLINE,
BRO.
>> IS THERE ANYWAY YOU CAN
GUARANTEE CHUCK YOU WILL NOT HIT
HIM?
>> I GUARANTEE YOU WILL NOT HIT
ME.
NOPE.
>> KIND OF CLOSE, BUT NO CIGAR.
>> I DON'T THINK CHUCK HAS HIT
ONCE.
>> CHEYENNE IS ON FIRE.
>> DUDE, HE'S LIKE SCRAPING THE
GROUND EVERY TIME HE SWINGS.
>> MAYBE HE'S HUSTLING US.
HE DOESN'T WANT US TO SEE HOW
GOOD HE IS AT GOLF.
>> WAS THAT CHUCK OR CHEYENNE?
>> IT WASN'T CHUCK.
>> TAKE A WILD GUESS.
>> IT DEFINITELY WASN'T CHUCK.
>> JUST GOT BEAT BY CHUCK.
>> CHUCK.
>> I TAKE IT ALL BACK.
>> OW, THAT HIT MY FOOT, I FELT
IT.
>> YOU ARE GETTING SMACKED BY
EVERYONE.
>> CHEYENNE IS HITTING MOVING
TARGETS TOO.
>> CHEYENNE IS MONEY.
>> HEY, IN THE COMMENTS,
OVER/UNDER, DO YOU THINK YOU'RE
BETTER OR WORSE THAN CHARLES
BARKLEY AT GOLF?
>> VERY HARD TO BE WORSE THAN
CHARLES.
I DON'T GOLF AND I THINK I'M
BETTER THAN CHARLES.
>> SEE, I SAY THAT AND ALL OF A
SUDDEN I GET OUT THERE.
>> HOW CAN YOU GONOT DO BETTER?
>> THAT'S A GOOD ONE, CHUCK.
>> NO, IT'S NOT.
>> SHOULD I DRIVE UNDER ONE FOR
HIM?
>> YOU MIGHT HAVE TO GO 2 YARDS
AWAY FROM HIM.
LET HIM GET THE PUTTER OUT.
>> TRY TO ADJUST AS HE SWINGS.
>> I'M COMING OUT.
>> HE SHOULD PULL THE CART RIGHT
IN FRONT OF THEM.
RIGHT AFTER THESE THREE ARE DONE
WARMING UP, WE'RE BRINGING OUT
THE BIG GUNS, TOM BRADY, AARON
RODGERS, PHIL MICHELSON AND
BRYSON DECHAMBEAU ARE COMING
OUT.
WHO DO YOU THINK IS GOING TO HIT
THE CART THE MOST OUT OF THOSE
FOUR?
THERE'S GOING TO BE SIX PEOPLE
WIN NING $500 ON THE CHALLENGE.
BRING OUT THE BIG BUCKS ON THIS
ONE.
LET US KNOW IN THE COMMENTS WHO
DO YOU THINK IS GOING TO HIT THE
CART THE MOST.
WIN 500 BUCKS JUST FOR BEING
HERE WITH THE BOYS IN THE
STUDIO.
>> THIS IS HARD TO WATCH.
>> THEY'RE GOOD, BROTHER.
BRAND NEW.
>> CHEYENNE WOODS IS LOVING
THIS.
SHE'S JUST BEAMING.
>> I'M GOING TO GET A SOUVENIR.
>> SHE IS MONEY.
>> GET HER TO SIGN ONE.
>> SHE IS CASH MONEY.
SHE DOES NOT MISS.
>> GETTING BEAT UP IN THERE.
>> IT'S TOO EASY FOR CHEYENNE.
>> FITZ IS NOT BAD AT ALL.
YOU GOT A SOUVENIR.
THERE'S A BALL BACK THERE!
DID YOU SEE THAT?
HE IS MOVING AND SHE'S STILL ON
TARGET, BRO.
WHAT?
>> IT'S IN HER BLOOD.
>> JESUS.
>> FOR EVERYONE HOME, THAT IS
TIGER WOODS' NIECE.
SHE'S A PROFESSIONAL GOLFER.
>> ELITE.
>> WES, I WOULDN'T TALK ANY SHIT
TO CHEYENNE.
>> CHUCK HAS TO AT LEAST GIVE US
ONE.
>> COME ON, CHARLES!
>> UNDER THE BRIDGE.
>> COME ON.
>> WE NEED AT LEAST ONE.
>> OH, MAN.
>> TELL HIM HE HAS TO RETIRE IF
HE DOESN'T HIT YOU, BRO.
HE HAS TO RETIRE FROM EVER
TOUCHING A GOLF CLUB.
>> THE WHOLE MEGAPHONE BROKE.
FITZ HAS BEEN PRETTY DARN GOOD
TOO.
>> JESUS, CHUCK.
>> I ACTUALLY LOVE IT.
I CAN'T BELIEVE CHEYENNE'S AS
GOOD AT THIS.
>> GO TO 100.
>> OH!
>> COPY THAT.
>> TAKE IT IN THE COMMENTS.
JD MAXWELL SAID HE WOULD RATHER
HAVE A PROVEN WINNER AND A GREAT
LEADER.
>> AARON RODGERS, I DON'T KNOW,
HE'S SKATING OUT.
>> JACOB, WHERE ARE YOU FROM,
BOSTON?
THAT'S THE ONLY WAY I'M
BELIEVING IT.
CHEYENNE JUST SENT WES OUT 100
YARDS.
CAN SHE DO IT?
>> IMAGINE THIS IS THE SHOT THAT
CHUCK --
>> HE GOES OUT IN 300 AND
CHUCK'S JUST BEAMING HIM EVERY
SINGLE TIME.
I LOVE IT.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, DON'T
FORGET WHO HITS THE CART MOST
OUT OF THE NEXT UP, WIN 500
BUCKS.
>> I CAN'T SEE ANYTHING, GUYS.
>> CHUCK KNOWS WHAT HE'S AIMING
AT.
>> CHUCK AND MICHELSON WON THE
MATCH, THOUGH.
HE WAS REALLY GOOD.
I THINK HE'S HUSTLING.
DO YOU THINK CHARLES BARKLEY IS
HUSTLING OUT THERE?
IS THAT IT?
WEST?
>> I MISSED IT.
I'M LOSING THE BALL, THOUGH.
CHE
CHEYENNE, THAT HAD THE CORRECT
DISTANCE, WE JUST NEED TO MOVE
IT LEFT A LITTLE BIT.
>> IF IT HITS ME, I'M TOAST.
>> I FEEL BAD.
I WANT CHRIS PAUL TO GET A RING.
I DON'T NEED THIS BAD OMWE OMEN
IN THE PHOENIX SUNS.
>> WHAT IS IT, A 7 IRON?
>> LOOKS LIKE BRADY, RODGERS,
PHIL AND BRYSON ARE ON THEIR WAY
OUT RIGHT NOW.
WEST, YOU'VE BEEN GETTING BEAMED
BY JUST ONE PROFESSIONAL GOLFER.
YOU'RE ABOUT TO HAVE TWO OUT
THERE.
>> WE HAVE SHATTERED PLEXIGLASS.
>> HE SIGNED A WAIVER.
>> HE SIGN SIGNED THE SAFETY WA
>> GOT TO MAKE SURE YOU HAVE
FUN.
>> THAT'S WHAT I WOULD SAY TOO
IF I WERE PLAYING ABSOLUTELY
HORRIBLY.
>> I'M NOT TRYING TO WIN.
I'M JUST OUT HERE TO HAVE SOME
FUN.
>> EVERY TIME.
HERE'S A REPLAY.
100 YARD BOMB FROM CHEYENNE.
SHE'S SO GOOD.
WAIT, I WANT TO SEE YOUR
PLEXIGLASS BREAK.
WEST, YOU'RE BEING DRAMATIC.
>> NO, GUYS.
IT DIDN'T SHATTER, BUT THERE'S A
CRACK.
>> HOW YOU FEELING?
BRYSON DECHAMBEAU AND PHIL
MICHELSON ARE COMING OUT?
>> I'M TRYING TO KEEP MY COOL,
BUT I DON'T FEEL TOO GOOD ABOUT
IT.
>> YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE FOUR
PEOPLE JUST AS GOOD AS CHEYENNE
COMING AT YOUR HEAD.
>> LOOK AT THE BOYS.
WOW.
BRADY'S KIND OF TALL.
ROD
RODGERS IS LOOKING LIKE ME OUT
THERE.
>> OH MAN.
>> THAT'S SUCH A FLEX.
WHAT A FLEX.
>> HOW YOU DOING?
>> YOU THINK BRADY AND RODGERS
ARE COOL?
>> YOU THINK THEY HAVE BEEF?
THEY'RE GETTING PAID.
THEY HAVE FAMILIES AND
EVERYTHING.
>> CHUCK JUST PUT HIS HANDS ON
HIS HIPS.
>> WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
>> IT'S OVER FOR HIM.
>> HE'S TIRED.
>> DUDE, HAS HE HIT ONE?
>> THERE'S A GREAT CHALLENGE
RIGHT THERE.
>> WILL CHARLES EVER HIT THE
CART?
FIND OUT ON THE NEXT EPISODE.
HOW FAR ARE YOU NOW?
>> I'M AT LIKE 75.
>> IF YOU'RE IN THE BLEACHER
REPORT APP YOU BETTER HAVE
GOTTEN YOUR COMMENTS IN BECAUSE
SIX OF YOU GET $500.
>> SHE JUST KNOCKED THE FLAG OFF
THE CART.
SHE JUST KNOCKED THE FLAG OFF
THE CART, BRO.
>> I DON'T THINK WE'RE GOING TO
BE ABLE TO MOVE CHEYENNE FROM
HERE.
>> LOOK AT THE FLAG.
GONE.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK THE VEGAS
ODDS WERE ON THAT?
WEST, DO NOT GET OUT.
YOU WILL DIE.
>> DON'T DO IT, BRO.
WE CARE ABOUT YOU.
WE DON'T WANT TO SEE YOU DIE.
>> APPRECIATE YOU.
THAT'S GOOD ADVICE.
>> HE'S GETTING THE DRIVER OUT.
HE'S GOT THE DRIVER OUT.
NOW, THERE IS ONE TWIST FOR
EVERYONE WATCHING RIGHT NOW.
LARRY, CHUCK AND CHEYENNE WERE
KIND OF JUST WARMING UP, SO
HITTING AS MANY AS THEY WANT,
BUT WE HAVE SOME EXTRA SPECIAL
STUFF FOR WHEN THE FOUR
SUPERSTARS GET OUT HERE.
THE PLAYERS GET TEN SHOTS EACH,
PLUS ONE SHOT AT THE END WITH A
GOLDEN BALL.
>> THE MONEY BALL.
>> THAT THING'S GOING TO BE
AWESOME.
VERY EXCITED FOR THAT.
WE'LL BE TALLYING THEIR SHOTS.
IT'S NOT JUST GOING TO BE A FREE
FOR ALL.
THERE WILL BE A SCORE AND A
WINNER.
EVERY SINGLE BALL THAT HITS THE
CART, WE'RE DONATING A THOUSAND
MEALS TO FEEDING AMERICA.
>> A THOUSAND MEALS TO CHARITY.
>> IS CHUCK JUST DRIVING AS FAR
AS HE CAN?
OH, WOW.
>> CHUCK'S GOING AT IT.
IF HE SHANKS ONE, YOU'RE IN BIG
TROUBLE.
>> GIVE ME ONE.
>> HE'S TAKING THE GLOVE OFF,
BRO.
IT'S OVER.
>> HE'S SO OVER IT.
HE'S DONE.
>> GIVE ME YOUR BEST CHUCK ROAST
IN THE COMMENTS.
I NEED TO KNOW.
>> SHAQ IS DEFINITELY
DISAPPOINTED.
SHAQ IS GOING TO GO ON "INSIDE
THE NBA" AND SAY THIS IS WHY I
HAVE THREE RINGS.
SOMEONE CORRECT ME IN THE
COMMENTS.
THIS IS GOING TO BE FUN.
>> I NEED YOU GUYS' BEST CHARLES
BARKLEY ROAST IN THE COMMENTS.
WE'RE GOING TO TELL HIM TOO.
>> FITZ HAS GOOD FORM TOO.
>> MR. FITZ.
>> DO YOU GUYS KNOW WHO'S HIT
MORE, LARRY OR CHEYENNE?
PROBABLY CHEYENNE.
>> THAT ANSWER ITS IT FOR YOU.
>> WEST IS IN A HIGH-STRESS
SITUATION RIGHT NOW.
>> CHUCK IS PULLING HIMSELF OUT
OF THE COMPETITION,
UNDERSTANDABLY.
>> CHUCK GAVE UP, BRO.
HE DROVE IT FOR LIKE 300 YARDS.
>> HE WAS FED UP WITH THE
SHENANIGANS.
>> IS HE GRABBING THE CLUB
AGAIN?
I THINK HE IS.
>> HE'S OUT, BABY.
I'M GOING TO PUT 5,000 MEALS
MYSELF IF CHARLES BARKLEY CAN
HIT THIS GOLF CART.
>> 10,000 MEALS.
>> OH MY GOD!
>> DID THAT HIT YOU, WEST?
>> NO.
>> OH!
>> THAT WAS SO CLOSE.
>> HE'S HUSTLING.
>> WHAT WAS THAT?
>> I TAKE IT BACK.
HE'S NOT HUSTLING US, LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN.
>> NOT FOR YOU.
>> TELL HIM PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
STARVE IF HE DOESN'T HIT THE
CART.
>> THERE WAS THE ONE.
>> HE'S PUTTING HIS CLUB AWAY.
>> GLOVES ARE GONE.
>> THEY'RE GETTING BOOTED.
THE BIG GUNS ARE COMING OUT.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, YOUR
WINDOW OF TIME TO GUESS WHO'S
GOING TO HIT THE CART MOST IS
CLOSING.
>> LET US KNOW IN THE COMMENTS.
>> SIX DIFFERENT PEOPLE.
THIS IS THE BIG ONE RIGHT HERE.
FOUR PEOPLE.
THERE'S ALREADY BEEN $800 GIVEN
AWAY.
FOUR PEOPLE GOT 200 EACH FOR
GUESSING CHEYENNE WAS GOING TO
HIT.
THE OBVIOUS GUESS HERE IS GOING
TO BE THE PRO GOLFERS.
>> DON'T EVER COUNT TOM BRADY
OUT.
>> THAT'S SUCH A GOOD QUESTION.
HOW FAR SHOULD WEST GO OUT ON
THIS?
WHAT ARE YOU THINKING, WEST?
>> I WANT TO GIVE HIM LIKE A
HARD ONE TOO, MAYBE LIKE 200,
SEE IF THESE GOLFERS ARE REALLY
CERTIFIED LIKE THAT.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK OF 125?
>> I LIKE THAT.
>> ALL RIGHT, WEST.
YOU WANT TO DIAL IT UP TO 125?
>> LET'S GO TO 125, WEST.
>> IN THE COMMENTS, LET US KNOW
WHAT YOU THINK IS A GOOD
DISTANCE.
IF THEY'RE DRILLING THEM FROM
HERE, MOVE THEM BACK.
>> I GUARANTEE THEY DRILL HIM
ALMOST EVERY TIME.
>> YOU THINK?
>> IT'S GOING TO BE LIKE A
METEOR SHOWER.
>> YOU'RE GIVING HIM NIGHTMARES.
>> ALL AT THE SAME TIME.
>> DON'T WORRY, LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN.
IT'S GOING TO BE A LITTLE HARD
TO KEEP TRACK OF THIS.
WE HAVE A SCORE TICKER FOR YOU
TRACKING WHO HITS WHAT.
AND WE HAVE THE INSTANT REPLAY
TOO.
IT'S SO EASY TO SPOT HIM WITH
THAT TV 12 HAT.
I WISH HE WASN'T SO HANDSOME.
>> THAT SWING IS CRISPY.
>> OF COURSE IT IS.
>> WHAT CAN'T THIS GUY DO?
>> SOMETHING CUSTOM.
>> THEY PROBABLY ARE CUSTOM.
BRYSON IS GOING TO ABSOLUTELY --
>> GEEZ, MAN.
GOOD LUCK, BRO.
>> THERE'S PAINT IN THE BED OF
THIS GATOR.
>> I WANT TO SEE MICHELSON.
>> OH MAN, WHO DO YOU GOT
WINNING, BRO?
>> WHO'S GOING TO HIT THE CART
THE MOST?
>> YEAH.
>> I'M GOING AARON RODGERS.
>> I'M GOING PHIL.
>> THEY'RE ABOUT TO START
SWINGING, BABY.
I'M SO ANNOYED.
>> LET US KNOW IN THE COMMENTS
WHO HITS THE CART MOST.
>> BLEACHER R ER REPORT APP.
DECHAMBEAU WITH ONE ON THE
BOARD!
BRADY, CHOKE, CHOKE!
AARON RODGERS OWNS YOU, BRADY.
>> AARON RODGERS' SWING LOOKED
PRETTY GOOD TOO.
>> MICHELSON JUST MISSED TWO.
DECHAMBEAU STRONG RIGHT NOW.
>> I CAN'T TELL WHO THE BALLS
ARE FROM.
>> WE CAN TELL UP HERE.
>> ONE FOR BRYSON SO FAR?
>> ONE FOR BRYSON.
THAT'S TWO HITS.
MICHELSON WITH A MISS.
DECHAMBEAU IS A MANIAC.
>> LET'S MOVE IN.
>> WEST, WE GOT TO BRING YOU IN,
MY MAN.
LET'S BRING HIM UP TO 50.
I WANT TO SEE SOME HITS.
MICHELSON WITH THE MOVING
TARGET.
BRING IT UP TO 50, BABY.
>> WE'RE NERVOUS FOR YOU, BRO.
>> ARE YOU AT 50?
BRING THAT PUPPY UP TO 50.
>> PHIL, OH!
>> THE PRO GOLFERS ARE TIED UP
AT 1-1.
OUR QUARTERBACKS WITH A BIG OLE
GOOSE EGG.
THAT'S WHAT I THOUGHT, TOM
BRADY.
YOU'RE BAD.
>> WHO WAS THAT?
>> MICHELSON.
>> RODGERS!
IT BOUNCED LEFT.
>> IS THAT OVER?
IT'S OVER.
>> I CAN SEE YOUR CALVES FROM
HERE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> DECHAMBEAU.
>> PHIL MICHELSON, MY MONEY'S ON
HIM.
>> BRADY SHANKS IT.
WEST, TAKE ME TO 50.
>> LET'S DO IT.
>> YEP.
HERE WE GO.
>> THERE IS GOING TO BE A GOLDEN
BALL.
>> YEAH, WE HAVE SOME SPECIAL
RULES.
DON'T EVEN WORRY ABOUT THAT
SCORE TOO MUCH YET.
RIGHT NOW 0-0-3-1.
THERE IS THE GOLDEN BALL.
THE GOLDEN BALL IS WORTH TRIPLE.
THEY GET ONE SHOT EACH TO HIT
THE DPGOLF CART.
THAT'S WORTH THREE.
>> YES, SIR!
YES, SIR, TOM!
>> MICHELSON WITH A LINE DRIVE.
>> HE'S LIGHTING IT UP.
>> HE IS.
I CAN'T BELIEVE DECHAMBEAU IS
TIED UP.
>> PHIL IS LIGHTING IT UP.
>> I CAN'T SEE.
>> ALL RIGHT, BOYS, THAT MEANS
THE GOLDEN BALL IS COMING OUT
RIGHT NOW.
LY SWE'RE GOING TO BE GIVING AWY
TRIPLE DONATIONS.
IT'S NOT POSSIBLE FOR BRADY,
RODGERS OR DECHAMBEAU TO BRING
IT BACK IN BECAUSE MICHELSON IS
SUCH A SNIPER.
>> OH WOW.
>> MICHELSON IS ON FIRE.
>> OH MY GOODNESS.
HE'S LIGHTS OUT.
>> LET'S SEE SOMETHING, TOM.
PRESSURE.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHERE IT WENT.
>> AS EXPECTED, TOM BRADY CHOKES
UNDER PRESSURE.
NO SHOCKS HERE, LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN.
>> OVERTHROWN.
>> DECHAMBEAU IS AS GOOD AS
BRADY AND RODGERS RIGHT NOW.
KOEPKA IS LOVING THIS.
LET'S SEE IF HE'S GOT IT.
NO THANK YOU.
>> YOU DIDN'T HAVE TO THROW THAT
SHOT, BRO.
>> THAT'S ALL I KNOW.
>> LET'S SEE IT, AARON.
>> ALL THAT'S LEFT IS AARON
RODGERS' GOLDEN BALL.
>> THIS IS A LANDSLIDE VICTORY.
PHIL MICHELSON, I KNEW IT.
>> YOU WERE SO RIGHT.
MICHELSON IS COMING IN HOT,
WEST.
>> THESE THREE GOT TO HAVE A
LITTLE SHOOTOUT OR SOMETHING.
8-1-1-1.
>> I THEINK THAT'S IT, WEST.
YOU'RE ALL SET THERE.
THAT'S THE BIG POINT ABOUT THE
CHALLENGE ON SCREEN RIGHT NOW.
THE QUESTION WAS, DOES ANYONE
HIT THE CART WITH THEIR GOLDEN
BALL?
IF YOU SAID YES BEFORE MICHELSON
STARTED SWINGING, YOU GOT IT
RIGHT AND YOU HAVE A CHANCE TO
BE ONE OF THE FOUR PEOPLE WHO
WINS $200.
>> WE DONATED 11,000 MEALS.
>> 11,000 MEALS.
>> I THINK I WANT THAT TO BE A
PRETTIER NUMBER.
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT 11,000?
I DON'T KNOW IF I'M ALLOWED TO
DO THIS BUT WE'RE SENDING THAT
PUPPY ALL THE WAY UP TO 50,000!
>> YES!
>> LET'S GO.
>> YES, SIR, 50,000 MEALS
DONATED.
>> I LIKE 50,000 A LITTLE BETTER
THAN 11,000.
WE'RE GOING TO TACK ON SOME OF
OUR OWN.
50,000 MEALS BEING DONATED.
AND WE GET TO SEE THESE STUDS
HANG OUT ON "RANGE BATTLES"
HERE.
I LOVE IT.
WEST, HOW WAS IT, BRO?
>> IT WAS GOOD.
THOSE BALLS MOVE FAST.
PHIL'S THE MAN, HUH?
>> HE'S SO GOOD.
>> IS HE OLDER THAN TOM?
>> HE IS, RIGHT?
HE'S ABOUT 50.
TOM'S LOW 40s.
>> THAT'S PROBABLY WHO MOTIVATES
TOM, IS MICHELSON.
>> THEY'RE ON THE TEAM TOGETHER,
RIGHT?
MICHELSON AND BRADY?
>> IT'S OVER.
>> HEY, YOU SURVIVED.
PLEXIGLASS DIDN'T GET YOU.
>> ALIVE, HEALTHY, NO INJURIES,
GOOD.
>> WE'RE GOOD.
>> THIS MAN WILLINGLY WENT OUT
THERE AND GOT PELTED.
>> OF COURSE.
>> ALL RIGHT.
DON'T GO ANYWHERE YET, LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN, BECAUSE THE WHOLE
POINT OF DOING THESE CHALLENGES
AND BEING WITH US HERE ON "RANGE
BATTLES" IS WE'RE GIVING AWAY A
LOT OF MONEY.
WE'RE DONATING A LOT TOO.
WE HAVE THE END OF SHOW WINNERS
COMING UP SOON.
FOR NOW I GET TO LOOK AT
RODGERS' BEAUTIFUL FLOW.
>> ARE YOU AARON RODGERS OR TOM
BRADY, BRO?
>> IT'S THE FLOW.
I LOVE THEM.
THAT'S THE GOLDEN BALL TOO.
THAT'S THE BIG GOLDEN BALL RIGHT
THERE.
>> PHIL IS MONEY.
>> IF YOU SAID YES, THERE WILL
BE A GOLDEN BALL HIT, THAT'S IT.
>> MONEY.
>> PHIL MICHELSON FOR $500.
THE LIST WENT AWAY.
>> YOU SAW THAT, BABY.
HE'S A STUD.
>> THAT WENT FAST, HUH?
>> IF YOU GUESSED THAT THE
GOLDEN BALL WOULD HIT --
>> JET SKI THE KID.
EMILY LOMBARDO.
>> EVEN IF YOU DIDN'T GUESS
CORRECTLY, YOU GOT TO HANG OUT
WITH US.
>> THAT MUST BE THE EASIER $200.
>> AND MICHELSON WON TOO.
I FEEL LIKE MICHELSON MIGHT HAVE
BEEN THE FAVORITE IN MOST HITS
ON THE CART.
>> NO QUESTION.
>> OUT OF TEN BALLS, HE HIT
FIVE.
THAT'S CRAZY.
>> THEN OF COURSE AS WE'RE
WARMING UP, CHEYENNE WOODS
KNOCKED OFF A POST ON THE CART
AND WAS DRILLING THAT THING.
SHE WAS THE FIRST HIT.
IF YOU GUYS DID YOUR RESEARCH,
YOU GOT AN EASY 200 RIGHT THERE.
LOOK AT HOW BEAUTIFUL THAT
LOOKS.
MONTANA.
>> WISH WE WERE OUT THERE.
>> I KNOW.
>> LOOKS LIKE A GREEN SCREEN,
BRO.
>> OF COURSE, LOOK, IT'S NOT ALL
GOLF TODAY.
A LOT OF YOU HAD SOME HILARIOUS
COMMENTS AND WE'RE GIVING AWAY
$
$100.
72 IS GETTING 100 BUCKS FOR THIS
ONE.
I LOVE THAT.
MIGHT BE AN MSU FAN.
THAT'S $100 WELL EARNED.
WE LOVE YOU THERE.
BRADY, STOP BEING SO HANDSOME.
LOOK AT MY PARTY SUIT.
YOU GUYS LIKE THE PARTY SUIT?
>> OH YEAH.
>> YOU THOUGHT I HAD A SUIT ON.
ARE YOU A CLOWN?
NO.
YOU GOT THAT PARTY SUIT.
TOM BRADY COULD NEVER, LITERALLY
NEVER.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, WE CANNOT
THANK YOU ENOUGH FOR JOINING US.
THIS HAS BEEN "RANGE BATTLES"
PRESENTED BY CAPITAL ONE.
AT 5:00 P.M. EASTERN IT'S BRADY
AND PHIL MICHELSON VERSUS AARON
RODGERS AND BRYSON DECHAMBEAU.
TAKE CARE, Y'ALL.